hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in from the fire
and you know what that means it's time
to tell a story and this one is about
all of my permanent scars of course you
guys already know about the chin that's
the most recent one and maybe it's not
even permanent by the way look at it
look how good I'm healing little patchy
but that thing was a mess I didn't think
the beard would ever grow back I was
really worried but look at me I never
looked better anyways let me tell you
about the first couple so if you watch
hot ones sometimes when they have the
shot on the guest you can see and if
I've got a fresh buzz you can see a
little scarring on the back of my head
and maybe some of you have wondered hey
what the hell's up with that well the
story is this I was very young maybe two
years old just walking and I decided to
take on the ambitious task of walking on
the couch meanwhile my parents making
dinner in the kitchen doing whatever no
one's supervising the two-year-old
walking around on the couch I lost my
balance went backwards and boom began my
long history of getting faced assaulted
by coffee tables it's something that
happened at the beginning of my life and
it's something that's now happening
later on in my life but you know what
since I was too young to tell the tale
I'm gonna call my dad and see firsthand
from this guy what that was like
oh hey I'm happy I got a hold of you
yeah so I'm doing a YouTube video so
this is being recorded what's the story
behind me busting my head open when I
was a kid I'm going through all my
permanent scars just sort of mastered
the art of walking and decided that well
since you're up so well on the floor you
can try walking across the sofa when she
doesn't really work cuz there's a lot of
give in the sofa cushions so you went
over backwards the back of your head on
the edge of the coffee table on your way
to the floor nice
do you remember were you at the house
when that happen oh yeah
yeah I picked you up and I had my hand
behind your head you were crying
and your mom was standing there holding
Gavin and she just turned pale and I
looked in those the blood come out the
back of your head now it's my first trip
with you to the emergency room alright
well thank you so much for the back
story the people appreciate it and I
love you and I miss you I have fun I'll
talk to you later bye
my other permanent scar so I've got at
least three three with stories at least
back in the head getting cocky walking
around on the couch cuz I now know how
to walk and then BOOM reality check
smashing my head against the table the
second story
fast forward to fifth grade sixth grade
I'm a little leaguer and I'm playing on
a team that has the Blue Jays uniform so
in the full Toronto Blue Jays uniform
and I've just taken some hacks in the
driveway waiting for my dad to come out
and my brother just so happens to be
shooting hoops in the driveway so I'm
like hey Gavin toss me a pitch and I've
got my bat back and I'm ready to just
bow
pop this basketball but let me tell you
that's a dangerous thing at home do not
try that because this is what happens i
go i take my Louisville Slugger hit that
fully inflated basketball made of rubber
and what happens BAM ricochet effect I
just go off the basketball busy
intersection Upper East Side
I just boom hit the basketball and then
with twice as much force with which I
swing it came back at me boom crashes me
right in the head I didn't feel anything
all I remember is it just hurt like I
just heard a car door slam that's all
that happened I I took the swing and
then I heard a car door slam that's what
it felt like to me and I'm like dazed
and woozy my brother is completely
freaked out and I have no idea why I
remember I put my head down and then it
felt like somebody just turned on a
faucet on the side of my head just blood
coming out of my head like a faucet I
rallied to my feet do my sort of boxer
in the 12th round walk to the to the
house my dad you know he's doing the
last-minute things before a little
league game filling up a water bottle
making sure everything is good to go and
he's getting ready to walk outside and
when I come up from behind him I just go
dad I hit my head and he turned around
and looked at me and said Jesus Christ
you did and then rushed me to the
emergency room I had to explain that
ridiculous story to so many doctors oh I
just hit a basketball and my the bat
came back and nearly killed me
so I was telling that story over and
over and over again six stitches on this
eyebrow I'll never forget it to this
eyebrow because I'm a righty
boom boom boom bang and that is the
story of the permanent scars it's
amazing that I'm still here to even tell
this story back of the head eyebrow chin
and still stand-in baby all right it's
time to recommend another foreign film
the whaling another Korean suspense
horror movie that I absolutely loved
it's like 28 days later me
The Exorcist but it's shot so
beautifully the scenes are so beautiful
the way it rains on that town you know I
love them I love them if you're not yet
on the Foreign Film bandwagon now is the
time to get on it I've been doing it all
quarantine and I need your
recommendations again this is me asking
again the fans of hot ones you guys know
what I like
hit me up let me know let me know I'm a
noob still let me know the films that I
need to watch thank you very much for
listening to this story about how I
busted my noggin a million-in-one
different ways but lived long enough to
tell the tale we'll see you next time
what's going on hot ones fans this is
Sean Evans checking in to say if you
haven't gotten your bottle of the last
dab xxx visit Keaton is calm Keaton is
calm to order it's a 10 out of 10 the
final boss on our hot ones gauntlet you
don't have to if you don't want to but
all things being equal I'd appreciate it
if maybe he gave it a try
[Music]